– Also, Herr Al-Pascha.
Ich habe noch fünfzig andere Bewerber.
Warum sollte ich Sie einstellen?
Was sind Ihre Stärken?
– Ich bin zuverlässig. Ich würde gern
in Ihrem Unternehmen arbeiten.
– Sind Sie teamfähig?
– ’tschuldigung, könnten Sie das
bitte wiederholen?
– Können Sie gut im Team arbeiten?
– Ja, ich habe in Syrien
immer im Team gearbeitet.
– Was haben Sie dort gemacht?
– Ich bin Arzt.
– Arzt? Dann haben Sie auch
eine Spezialisierung, oder?
– Ich bin Urologe.
– Aha.
Haben Sie Erfahrung im Schichtdienst?
– Natürlich.
Aber ich würde gern
nachmittags und abends arbeiten,
weil ich vormittags noch
einen Sprachkurs besuche.
– Das ist kein Problem.
Wollen Sie Teilzeit oder Vollzeit arbeiten?
– Ich möchte Vollzeit arbeiten.
– Hm …
Ich sehe Sie Montag
um vierzehn Uhr am Arbeitsplatz.
Dann klären wir alles Weitere.
– Bedeutet das …?
– Sie haben den Job. Erst einmal
befristet auf drei Monate.
Willkommen im Team, Herr Al-Pascha.
– Danke!
– Gut gemacht! Das wird schon.